so for months and months and months
we've been covering the story the
Canadian shop teacher who pulled his
entire class into his very obscure
sexual fetish by wearing size Z
prosthetic breasts and calling himself
Kayla Lemieux
because it kind of tells you everything
why is this allowed there are kids in
the class
so this guy's finally been placed on
leave the school board in Ontario only
took the steps after parents some of
them immigrant parents threatened to sue
the school this went on for so long
because there is a well-funded effort to
erase women of course both in Canada and
the United States
feminists are all for it it's always
your leaders to sell you out Hershey's
by the way is now putting the face of a
man posing as a woman on chocolate bar
wrappers this dude is called Faye
Johnstone called himself a proud
and said his female critic should be
vilified so they quote don't dare to
speak their views publicly okay here's
Faye Johnson not a fascist or anything
who by the way runs a quote LBGTQ
consulting firm that makes a ton of
dough from Canada's government watch
my name is Faye Johnstone I'm the
executive director of wisdom to action
we can create a world where everyone is
able to live in public space as their
honest and authentic selves see the
woman changing how we see the future at
Hershey's Canada
I mean like what
women don't worry we're not replacing
you don't worry everything's cool javik
Morris with The Spectator he joins us
tonight Kevin I got so many questions
you've been one of them like where do we
make up all these jobs the economy is
degrading and this dude has found a job
dressing like a woman wearing a nose
ring and then he's gotten hired by
Hershey's like is there a major for that
in college like where do these jobs come
from
well first of all happy International
women's awareness month or whatever it
is right now uh you know uh we all like
a little nuts in our chocolate I don't
see what the big deal is I love nuts in
my chocolate so I think it's perfectly
fine I think it's a real uh tragic start
to women's history awareness month that
this uh shop teacher her who I think we
all agree is uh delicate and as lovely
and temperate as a summer's day really
is under investigation for maybe not
being really trans when did we start
saying questioning people's identity
like this uh she also not I'm not if
you're I'm not sure if you're aware of
this but aside from being transgender
she's also disabled she suffers from
gigantomastia which is an unusual
swelling of the breast tissue in her
case it's prosthetic breasts which
apparently become sentient and swelling
on their own uh so you know this is just
how it is now if you say you're a woman
that's how it is and women seem to be
okay with it because very few are
picking up and being loud about being
erased in this way and taken over by men
in dresses and they talk about
mansplaining though I mean isn't this
the ultimate mansplaining I'm a woman
now you shut up ladies and they're like
okay I'll shut up
some dude just like a woman
to be a woman
yeah well I mean you don't want to get
knocked down and bruised by those
prosthetic breaths I wouldn't challenge
that guy either
that's a you know what that's a very
good point Chadwick Moore Common Sense
intrudes thank you so much for coming on
tonight
thank you my pleasure
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight